J.MICHAEL MCBRIDE: OK.
So more today about the lore of
acids and acid derivatives,
which you'll find in chapter 17,
18.
We'll get on, maybe at the end,
to chapter 19, but
probably that's for Friday.
At the end last time, we were
talking about having an R
minus, that is an organometallic
molecule react
with an acid, and showed that,
of course, the first thing it
does is act as a base, not as a
nucleophile, and pull off
the proton.
But even at that stage, it's
possible for another one to
come in and add to the carbon
oxygen double bond to give
this di-salt.
And then when this is hydrolyzed
at the end of the
day, you get a ketone, so you
could convert an acid to a
ketone that way.
But it's difficult.
Because sometimes, it's not
possible to
do it in two stages.
Here you stopped at the
dilithium salt.
Then you got rid of the R minus
when you added acid and
got the ketone.
But in the case of using
hydride, rather than R minus,
as the base nucleophile, again
you
first make the salt.
But the second time around, you
can get the aluminum,
also, as the salt of the oxygen.
And when you have that, that's
not a bad leaving group.
It's better than the O-lithium,
the O-aluminum.
So that it's possible to do an
elimination reaction where the
electrons of the lithium-oxygen
bond, or the oxygen
anion, help push out the
aluminum-oxygen anion, so that
in situ, while you're doing the
reaction,
it forms the aldehyde.
Bear in mind in the first step,
in the first reaction,
when we used the alkyl lithium,
we got the carbonyl
group back only after adding
acid.
Here it forms again while the
reaction is going on.
And of course, aldehydes are
reactive with
lithium aluminum hydride.
So you don't stop at the
carbonyl.
You go all the way to the
alcohol adding two Hs.
We'll see a little bit later
ways to try to control that.
Now, decarboxylation is another
interesting reaction
of carboxylic acids, and in
particular, of diacids, like
malonic acid, which has two acid
groups attached to the
same carbon.
This is this scheme that
Mitsunobu used in his paper to
talk about making the compound
at the bottom right that we
discussed last time or the time
before that.
Now remember, first he got this
compound by forming that
carbon-carbon bond.
And it has two esters and a CN
triple bond, but we said that
it was possible to convert the
ester into an acid.
We'll talk about this a little
bit more.
And the other ester into an
acid, and the cyanide, also,
the nitrile group, into an acid.
Now, I've drawn that acid in an
interesting
conformation here.
Because you see a possibility--
this doesn't happen when you
have the anion, but when you
have the protonated carboxylate,
and you have two
of them, it's possible to do
this reaction.
So you use these electrons to
form a bond to that hydrogen.
These go here, these go down
here.
What's the product at the top
from this cycle?
Can you see what it is?
What did the carbon at the top
become?
Carbon dioxide.
PROFESSOR: Carbon dioxide,
right.
So you have CO2.
That'll fly off.
It's a decarboxylation.
And you're left with this, which
is an enol.
And of course, that can undergo
an allylic
rearrangement to the ketone form
of the enol,
and the H go on here.
And then you have the product.
So when you have two carboxyl
groups on the same carbon, and
it's protonated so that you can
do this cyclic mechanism
to transfer the proton, then you
can easily lose CO2 and do
a decarboxylation.
But there are other ways to do
decarboxylations from acid.
The CO2 could be a leaving group
also from XCO2 minus,
where X is something that can
tolerate a negative charge, or
from the RCO2 radical.
So for example, carbonic acid,
the hydrate of CO2.
If it's an acid; it's also a
base.
So if you get this form, then
you can see how it can undergo
decarboxylation.
So that's just the reverse of
the hydration of CO2.
So carbonic acid and CO2 go back
and forth.
So that's a case where the X can
leave
with an unshared pair.
Or carbamic acid, where it's
nitrogen that does the trick,
and you can see the same kind of
thing to get a
decarboxylation.
Or we actually mentioned last
semester already Kolbe
electrolysis, where it's a free
radical that does it.
So you start with a carboxylate
anion, but you do
an oxidation to remove an
electron from it, which then
makes this free radical.
But that free radical is
fabulously unstable when R
is an alkyl group.
And it undergoes this shift of
the electrons-- single
electrons, it's a radical
process-- which is fast. Even
at 4 Kelvin you can't see an ESR
spectrum of this thing.
Even at that very low
temperature it immediately
loses CO2 and gives the free
radical,
even if it's not a
particularly stable free
radical.
So you remember Kolbe used that,
unbeknownst to
him, to make R2.
R2 was ethane, remember?
He thought he had made the
methyl, but once molecular
weights were determinable, it
turned out that he actually
had the dimer, ethane.
And in fact that reaction can
work fairly well
synthetically, to take two
acids, knock out two CO2s, and
have the Rs come together.
That was done in 1848.
But in 1973, they got a 50%
yield by doing electrolysis
that generates this free radical
by losing CO2 from it,
and the dimer was formed.
OK.
So there are examples of
decarboxylation.
But, also there's another one
that's interesting.
Which is to treat an acid with
silver oxide, which gives a
silver salt of the acid.
Then if you treat that with
bromine, you get R-Br.
So you can convert a carboxylic
acid to the alkyl
bromide with one less carbon
atom.
A decarboxylation has been
involved.
And it's pretty easy to see how
that would work.
If you react the salt with Br2,
the O minus can do a
nucleophilic substitution on
bromine with bromide leaving
to give this brominated
intermediate.
But now, if you have a free
radical in there, it can
attack the bromine to form the
R-Br bond and generate this
radical, which, as we've already
seen, immediately
loses CO2 and gives-- so we have
a free radical chain that
allows this brominated acid to
become RBr.
Now, this reaction--
to convert an acid to an alkyl
bromide--
is called the Hunsdiecker
reaction, for a sort of
curious reason, it seems to me.
Between 1936 and 1944, the
Hunsdieckers, husband and
wife, published, I think,
something like six patents for
doing this, and one paper in the
open literature.
But in fact, the same reaction
had been done in 1861 and
published in a leading German
journal, Annalen, by Alexander
Porfiryevich Borodin, who was
obviously much earlier than
the Hunsdieckers.
This is his tomb in Saint
Petersburg.
And notice that it doesn't have
anything about doing this
reaction on it,
because he was not only a
chemist,
he was also a musician.
So can you--
I know some of you are good
musicians.
Can you see what this line is,
up at the top?
What is it?
STUDENT: The Polovtsian Dances.
PROFESSOR: Polovtsian Dances by
Borodin, from Prince Igor.
And in fact, although he didn't
get any recognition in
terms of the reaction being
named for him-- these people
that came along 75 years later
got the credit--
he did get a posthumous Tony
award.
Because that tune, you know--
[SINGS]
dah dah dah dah dah dah dah dah
dah dah dah--
is the theme of the musical
Kismet.
So he came out OK, anyhow.
OK.
But now, when we think about--
so here's a way to take RCO2
and make it into RBr.
Right?
When you're thinking about
possibilities of synthesis,
you should think about, is there
a way to
go the other direction?
To start with RBRrand go to the
acid with
one additional carbon?
So can you add a carbon to do
that?
Can anybody think of a way of
doing that?
To take RBr and substitute the
Br with an acid group, CO2,
put another carbon on the chain?
We'll actually talk about this
some more later.
But we had shown an example that
if you have cyanide--
which is a nucleophile, so you
could do an SN2 reaction, put
cyanide there--
but cyanide has the same
oxidation state of the carbon
as the acid does.
So just treating it with water,
and either acid or
base-- and we'll talk about this
little later on-- and heat
can do that.
So you can go either direction.
You can take the acid to the
bromide, or the
bromide to the acid.
And that's not the only way.
Notice that this involves the R
being R plus, the thing with
the LUMO, the sigma* that gets
attacked by the cyanide.
But there's another way to start
with RBr
where R is R minus.
It's a HOMO that does the
attacking.
So how would you convert RBr
into something that's like R
minus, something that has a high
HOMO?
Under what circumstances does R
behave like R minus, is it
associated with a high HOMO?
STUDENT: With a halogen?
PROFESSOR: When it's associated
with a halogen,
it's a low LUMO, right?
And it's the sigma*.
But how can you get the stigma
to be high energy?
STUDENT: Use a Grignard reagent.
PROFESSOR: A Grignard reagent!
So if you want R minus, you make
a Grignard reagent.
And now you have to react that
in order to get an acid.
What will you react it with?
What will it attack in order to
put the
carbon and oxygens on? Ruoyi?
STUDENT: Carbon Dioxide.
PROFESSOR: Carbon dioxide.
It's exactly the reverse of the
reaction we're talking
about here.
So you bring carbon dioxide in,
you get the salt, treat it
with acid, and you do it.
So there are many ways to skin
these cats.
OK.
So we're talking about acid
derivatives.
We've just been talking about
acids.
But acid derivatives are things
where you have some
other group there, X, with an
unshared pair, not OH.
So one example that's called an
acid derivative is a
nitrile, that we just talked
about.
Another one is a ketene.
Now let's think about how these
are regarded as acid
derivatives.
There, as we just mentioned in
the last slide, the carbon has
a +3 oxidation level, because X
is electronegative,
something with the unshared pair
there.
And in nitrile, it's also +3.
So you can go between these
things and acid just by
treating them like water.
Although you may need catalysts
and a high
temperature in order to do it.
Nitriles are not so easy to do.
Remember he refluxed it for 24
hours or something like that,
Mitsunobu did, in order to do
this.
OK.
That's fine.
But over here, the carbon is +2
in
its oxidation level.
It doesn't look like you're
dealing with the same thing.
However, this other carbon is
-2.
And if you go to the acid, it's
-3, +3.
So it's, again, no change in
overall oxidation level.
So you don't need an
oxidizing/reducing agent,
and you can just
do that with water.
So ketene will react with water
to give
a carboxylic acid.
So all these things are called
acid derivatives.
First, just a word about the
spectroscopy.
In fact, I'll go in about three
seconds through the
first slide, because we've
already
done it in some detail.
Remember, we looked at carbonyl
stretching
frequencies in the IR, and saw
that aldehydes and ketones
were similar, but the amide was
much lower frequency,
because of the unshared pair on
the nitrogen being
involved stabilized by the
carbon oxygen pi*, and
therefore weakening it to make
it a weak bond.
But in the case of the ester the
bond was, in fact,
strengthened a bit.
And the case of acid chloride,
it was
strengthened quite a bit.
And that the reason for that was
that you could get this
other curious resonance
structure.
So we already did this, and I'm
not spending any time just
reminding you of it.
The one thing I'll talk about
that's new is the anhydride,
which is of course an acid
derivative where the X group
that's attached to the carbonyl
is another acid.
So here we see an IR spectrum,
and here is the percent
transmission.
So this is very little light
getting through.
A strong absorption means a
small number here.
And if we look in this region,
here's the carbonyl region, we
see that there are two peaks,
which isn't surprising,
because there are two carbonyls.
There's one at 1819, which is
very strong, and another one
at 1750, which is considerably
weaker.
Now two carbonyls, two IR
frequencies, two IR peaks.
That seems to make sense.
Except that it's symmetrical.
Wouldn't you expect them to be
the same?
STUDENT: There's an asymmetrical
frequency.
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
STUDENT: There's an asymmetrical
frequency.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So they couple.
They could either both be
stretching at the same time,
or one can be stretching while
the other's shrinking.
And if they're close enough
together, separated only by
one oxygen, they can interact
mechanically one another, and
one of those is easier than the
other.
So there are two normal modes,
both involve
both of the CO bonds.
Right?
And we can understand how it
would be.
Because if they're in phase,
both stretching at the same
time, then the light will
interact very
strongly with it.
Because both of them were being
stretched by the same
direction of the electric field
of the light.
And it turns out that that's
difficult to do.
It's difficult to stretch them
both at the same time.
It's better to have one stretch
when the other
shrinks, in terms of energy.
So this one is hard to do.
That means it's at high
frequency.
But it's quite intense, because
they're both going the
same direction.
The other normal mode would have
one going up while the
other's going down.
Now, if they were strictly
parallel, there would be no
net interaction with the light
for that.
But if they're twisted a little
bit, or splayed out a
little bit, then there will be
some interaction with light.
They won't exactly cancel one
another.
And that's what happens here.
So you have a strong peak where
they're both stretching
at the same time, and a weaker
peak where one is stretching
and the other is shrinking.
Now, if you compare that with
this cyclic imide, which is
another acid derivative where
nitrogen is attached to the
acyl group, and now we look at
the peaks here, and you see a
strong peak at low frequency and
a weak
peak at high frequency.
So it's exactly the opposite.
Can you see why it would be the
opposite?
Because now, when they both
stretch at the same time... when
one stretches and the other
shrinks, the oxygens are
moving in the same direction.
So they're both being pushed the
way light
wants them to go.
So that one, which is now the
easy one to do, where you
stretch one and shrink the
other, is now very strong.
It interacts strongly with
light.
But the one where they're
in-phase, here,
is now very weak.
They nearly cancel one another.
That's just an interesting
additional
example of IR coupling.
But it helps you see how you use
the IR to interpret stuff
about structure, as to whether
two carbonyls are parallel or
antiparallel most of the time.
OK, now, the interconversion,
the chemistry of the acid
derivatives.
So the idea is that some
nucleophile comes in and forms
the bond, and then the other one
leaves.
So that's a substitution.
But of course, it involves a
tetrahedral intermediate.
It's not like SN2.
You actually have an association
to give it a
stable intermediate, followed by
dissociation.
So it's not a pentavalent
transition state.
It's a tetrahedral, tetravalent
carbon
intermediate.
Now, which group will leave from
that
intermediate, X or Y?
Well, there's a hierarchy of
these things.
The easiest thing to leave is
chloride, then carboxylic
acid, then an alcohol anion,
then a nitrogen anion.
And you can see why this would
be.
Why so?
Because that's the order of
stability
of the anions, right?
As exemplified in the pKa.
So if you could make the most
energetic one, the top one,
the acid chloride, then by
adding the others
successively, you could make it
into any of the other
three; or the next one, the acid
anhydride, into either of
the other two; or the ester into
the amide, and so on.
So the important thing is to get
up at the top of the
ladder at the beginning.
And you can do that.
The same way you converted
alcohol to RCl, you can
convert an acid to the acid
chloride by using SOCl2.
And, as I was saying, out of
order before, this order of
the hierarchy is clear because
of the pKas.
They're in the order of the
stability of the anions.
But it's not just the stability
of the anions that
makes them have that order.
Because as we saw before, you
get resonance stabilization of
the electrons that are on Y.
That is, whatever this group
is here, chlorine, oxygen,
oxygen, nitrogen.
Right?
Those electrons are stabilized
by the vacant orbital here, as
denoted by these resonance
structures.
So even if you didn't have the
question of the stability of
the anions, the stability of the
derivatives would
still be the same.
It likes most to be with
nitrogen, because it can get
the special stability from
stabilizing the high energy
electrons of the nitrogen.
It's lower if it's an oxygen.
It's still lower if it's a
carboxylate group, because
although it's an oxygen's
unshared pair, as in the case
of alcohol, that electron pair
on that oxygen is already
stabilized by its own carbonyl
group.
So it's not as available for
being
stabilized by the one here.
So this one is not as stable as
that, this one is not as
stable as that.
And what that means is, you
don't have to do this with
base in order to get these
anions, in order to have this
reactivity scale.
You could do the same thing if
you had acid catalyzed.
And we've already seen it in the
case of Fischer
esterification, where now it's a
question
of alcohol and water.
That is, are you going to put on
OR, or are you
going to put on OH?
And we've gone through the acid
catalyzed mechanism of
Fischer esterification, which
converts OH to
OR, or OR to OH.
And you can also do
transesterification.
You can take one ester and a
different alcohol and have
the OR' replace OR", or
something like that.
You can go back and forth from
one ester to the other.
But the equilibrium constant for
this acid-catalyzed
process is one.
There's not much difference
among the different Rs.
But you make it go the way you
want in a Fischer
esterification by using the law
of mass action.
You put in a whole bunch of
alcohol, then
you get that ester.
Or you put in a whole bunch of
water, and then you get the
carboxylic acid.
So going back and forth between
ester and acid also is
very much like these
transesterifications.
But if you use base, it's a
different story.
So you could have hydroxide come
in and OR minus go out.
That's fine.
And it looks like it should be
an equilibrium
constant of about one.
But in fact, this reaction has a
special name,
saponification,
and it has an equilibrium
constant much
greater than one.
Now, why should there be a
difference between OR and OH,
an enormous difference?
It's because this isn't the end
of the line.
That OR minus that disappeared
can get back into the act.
In what way?
Sebastian?
STUDENT: Lose the hydrogen.
PROFESSOR: Right.
This is not called an acid for
nothing.
So it can transfer the proton to
the OR minus.
And now that's very favorable.
Because the pKa of the acid is
about 5, the pKa of a typical
alcohol is about 16.
So they differ by 11 orders of
magnitude.
That means the equilibrium
constant is about 10 to the
11th, when you factor in that
you that you don't stop
at the acid, but go to the anion
of the
acid, and to the alcohol.
Now, why does this thing have a
special name,
saponification, this particular
substitution reaction?
Because you have these things
called triglycerides, which
are long chain acids attached as
esters to a
three carbon unit.
You know what else you call
those things besides
triglycerides?
STUDENT: Fats.
PROFESSOR: Fats.
And if you treat fat with lye,
you're doing something that's
been known through millennia.
Right?
Because lye is what you get when
you take the ashes from a
fire and filter water through
it, and then
evaporate the water.
You know what you get?
What lye is?
It's potassium hydroxide.
So treat it with KOH, and you
have this reaction take
place. So you get carboxylic
acids, long-chain carboxylic
acids, and you get alcohols on
all those three.
So these long-chain fatty acids,
the salts of them, the
potassium salts, are called
what?
Why is it called saponification?
What's savon or sapone, right?
STUDENT: Soap.
PROFESSOR: It's soap.
So that's how soap was made.
And still is made.
And that stuff is called
glycerin, that trialcohol.
Now, there's a very interesting
book about lore in
the Appalachian mountains called
The Foxfire Book.
Has anybody seen that?
There was a movie made from it a
long time ago, actually.
But a bunch of high school
English students had the project
of going out and talking to
people who knew how to do
things, and then writing the
traditional lore.
And one of the people they
talked to was the grandmother
of one of the girls, whose name
was Pearl Martin,
and who made soap.
And so she showed the girls--
she had a big kettle, and put
in lard, and put in lye, and
stirred it up.
And she says, there, now the
soap's making, and so on.
And so she got the soap out, and
she said, you know,
"I could wash my hair in it."
And the girls were astounded
that she would wash her hair
in this stuff that
came from lie.
But she said, "I ain't afraid to
wash my hair in it."
She said, "That there
lard eats the lye."
What did she mean by that?
She, of course, hadn't studied
chemistry, at least I don't
believe, although she had very
good practical
knowledge of it.
That she knew that she could
wash her hair with this stuff,
even though you put lye in it.
The girls were dumbfounded at
this.
But the reason is that the lard
"ate" the lye.
The lye was like RO minus,
right? pKa of about 16.
But this last stage that makes
the reaction go makes it a
carboxylate with a pKa of only
5, so it
doesn't hurt your hair.
So there's some tradition for
you.
Now, an interesting question is,
what happens when the
nucleophile is R minus, or H
minus, rather
than these other things?
So I'm going to put a little bit
of this on the board.
And there's a--
see, I should put this up, put
this thing over
on the other screen.
Actually, it's supposed to be
there.
Yeah, there it is.
So let me put this up--
get some light here.
OK.
So what if you have R minus or H
minus as the nucleophile?
So suppose we start, and these
are for reactions with acid
derivatives.
Suppose we use the acid
fluoride.
Then if we use hydride, for
example,
lithium aluminum hydride--
so the AlH4 minus, high HOMO
there--
OK, so hydride can come in here.
Put minus on the oxygen.
Chloride can leave. And we get
aldehyde.
But the reaction won't stop
there, because we already know
that aldehydes are reduced by
lithium aluminum hydride.
So we'll go on to put two
hydrogens on, and make this,
and ultimately when you add an
acid, you'll get all the way
to the alcohol, not just to the
aldehyde.
So it's not just a substitution
of chloride by
hydride, but you go on all the
way to the product.
Or if you have an alkyl lithium,
or an
alkyl magnesium bromide.
You do the same kind of thing.
You get the--
now it would be a ketone first,
because
this is an R group.
But again, you go on and get the
alcohol, having put on two
new R groups.
So if that's the kind of alcohol
you want, with two R
groups, there's two R groups of
the same kind that you can
get from an alkyl halide, then
that's a good way to do it.
Now, if you use an ester, I'll
just write, ditto.
If you react it with lithium
aluminum hydride,
you get all the way
to the alcohol, replacing now
the OR minus,
instead of the Cl.
Or if you use alkyl lithium or
alkyl magnesium bromide, you
go all the way to the alcohol.
In fact, a particularly
interesting one is to use two
chlorines or two esters.
Can you see what would happen in
that case, if you reacted
those with the hydride, or with
the R minus, an alkyl
metal compound?
What's going to be different?
Well, if you went through, you
replace the chloride by R
minus, same kind of trick we're
doing here, or H minus.
Then you replace the other
chloride by
H minus or R minus,
you get an aldehyde or a ketone.
And then you add to the
carbonyl.
So now we put three groups on.
So we have a COH at the end with
three R groups.
You could do the same thing with
the hydride, but there
wouldn't be much point in making
methanol that way.
You're using expensive reagents
to
make something cheap.
But if you want something that
has three of the same R groups
on it, that could be a practical
way
of going about it.
It's slightly different if
you're using an amide.
So suppose you use lithium
aluminum hydride.
Now we'll get--
just call this R, here.
So we have NH2 and H minus that
came in.
Now, what we've done above is
then to lose this group that
was originally there.
Lose chloride, or lose O minus,
RO minus.
But it's a little different
here.
Because with the aluminum salt
here, the aluminum helps make
this oxygen a better leaving
group than it
would otherwise be.
So instead of coming like this
and losing the nitrogen, what
happens is the unshared pair
helps you lose the oxygen.
So the nitrogen is not lost.
It's still there, as N double-
bond now, H, and two Hs on
there.
But now that's rather like a
carbonyl group, right?
So the H minus can get...the
lithium aluminum hydride can
get in the act again.
And the product from lithium
aluminum hydride reduction of
an amide is an amine.
OK.
So now these are examples, then,
of going all
the way to the COH.
The carbonyl is completely gone,
and you added two, or
in one case, three groups.
But you might actually want the
intermediate.
You might want the aldehyde.
So the question arises, is there
a way to stop It, so you
can get that intermediate
product?
And you can do that.
You can stop by tuning the
nucleophile, so that it's able
to react in the first reaction
but not reactive
enough to react in the second.
So for example, instead of using
lithium aluminum
hydride, use lithium aluminum
hydride but that instead of
having other hydrogens on it,
has O-t-butyl
taken three times.
Now, there are two things about
having
that in place of hydrogen.
The first is that the oxygen is
electron withdrawing.
It stabilizes anions.
So it makes the electrons here
that are going to be doing the
attacking--
the sigma electrons--
it makes them lower in energy
and less reactive.
What else about having the
t-butyl group here would help
in mitigating the reactivity of
that tri-t-butoxy lithium
aluminum hydride?
Rahul?
STUDENT: Steric hindrance.
PROFESSOR: Right.
It's big, so it's hard to
approach.
OK.
So it's reactive enough to take
the acid chloride to the
aldehyde, but not to take the
aldehyde in the second step.
But it's used at very low
temperature, at dry ice
temperature, so that that second
reaction won't happen.
Or you can use, in a very
similar situation, a reagent
called DIBAL.
Again, you use it at minus 78
degrees.
And it's again an aluminum
hydride, but now again, it
doesn't have the oxygens, but it
has two isobutyl groups
which, again, are big and help
tame it.
So that one can be used with the
ester.
And take it over to the
aldehyde.
Or another way of getting from
the acid chloride and stopping
at the aldehyde is to do it with
H2 and a catalyst.
So the acid chloride, reduce it
to put H2 on
the ends of the bond.
But of course, the aldehyde can
also be reduced.
So you tame the reactivity of
the catalyst by adding a
nitrogen-containing compound,
quinoline.
This is called the Rosenmund
procedure.
We saw this before.
The idea of a catalytic
hydrogenation where are you
make the catalyst less reactive
in order to stop it.
Remember what that was, way back
when?
STUDENT: Acetylene to alkene.
PROFESSOR: Right. The
Lindlar catalyst,
where you wanted to
take a triple
bond and go just to a double
bond, but not from the double
bond to a single bond.
It was, again, the case of
adding something that would
poison the catalyst.
And finally, just as a reminder,
it's possible to
have an acid chloride and react
it with a very, very
weak carbon nucleophile that
only will react if you soup up
the chloride by using AlCl3 to
help make that a
good leaving group.
Now you can use a really weak
carbon nucleophile, high HOMO
on carbon, that will react to
give the ketone, but won't
react with the ketone, because
it's so weak.
Here you did a special thing to
help make the chloride
reactive, but it doesn't help
make a
ketone you get reactive.
Remember what the nucleophile is
you used in this?
An acyl chloride/AICI3?
What is it?
Acylation.
So you could use benzene as the
nucleophile.
We talked about it from the
point of view of something
attacking benzene, but now we're
looking at
it the other way.
Benzene attacking the something
else.
Right?
So we make the aromatic ketone
that way, by
Friedel-Crafts acylation.
But again, it's a question where
you could do the first
one, but not the second one, by
tuning the reactivity of
the reagents.
OK.
Now acid-, base-hydrolysis of
RCN.
Let me just use the other board
here for a moment.
So we talked before about
converting the CN to a
carboxylic acid.
And we can we can go through
acid- and base-catalyzed
mechanisms of doing that.
It's very simple, and I've got a
blackboard realization of
that, just to trace through it
quickly.
So you have the nitrile, the CN
group. Protonated it.
You have a resonance structure,
that has + on carbon.
React that with water, so now
you've got the C-O bond.
Lose a proton, so you have the
alcohol here now.
But then protonate the nitrogen.
Now we have this.
But if you take a base and pull
off this proton,
you have the amide.
In other words, this is an
allylic rearrangement.
It's a hydrogen here that goes
to the other end of this
double bond.
So you can get partway to the
acid.
You get from this acid
derivative to this acid
derivative, the amide.
But now suppose you protonate
this back again and get to
this one, which I've redrawn
here, and have that carbon
plus attacked by water.
So now a second water attacking
the carbon.
And take the proton off here,
and put it on the nitrogen,
and then have the NH3 leave with
the electrons.
You have this cation, lose a
proton, and now you're all the
way to the carboxylic acid.
So there are two stages of
substituting water here.
First adding water to give the
amide, and then changing the
amide acid derivative into the
acid itself.
So that's acid catalysis.
And I won't spend more time on
it now, but it would be good
for you to be able to do that.
But you can also do it with
base.
So in base, you attack the CN
triple bond, as if it were a CO
double bond.
Generate this, put a proton on,
and now do the allylic
rearrangement, the same thing we
did before, except that now
instead of being acid-catalyzed,
it's base-
catalyzed, so we're halfway
there.
We're to the amide, once we put
the last proton on.
And now we can go from the
amide, attack it, and then
lose the NH2, probably in a
protonated form.
Then we have the carboxylic acid
and drive it all the way
to completion in base, as in the
case of saponification, by
making the anion, the stable
carboxylate anion.
OK.
So there, both acid and base
could be used.
But it's a hard reaction to do.
It has to be heated a lot.
And sometimes people even do it
using biological catalysts
to try to get it down to a lower
temperature.
Now, a ketene, we said, was
another acid derivative.
So if you have an acid chloride
and react it with an
amine, we've just been talking
about reactions like this,
where the product--
you lose chloride, add nitrogen,
and the
product is an amide,
the carbonyl with nitrogen next
to it.
But this is a special case,
because there are three alkyl
groups on the nitrogen.
Do you see how that makes it
special?
Ayesha?
If you use the nitrogen as a
nucleophile, and attack, and
chloride leaves, then you have N
plus.
Right?
Because you've used the unshared
pair to
make that new bond.
And normally, what would you do
with that N plus?
How would you get rid of the
charge?
STUDENT: Lose a proton.
PROFESSOR: Normally, you'd lose
a proton from the amine.
But this time, we used a
trialkyl amine,
so it can't do that.
So in fact, it doesn't do it.
It probably attacks sometimes.
Chloride probably leaves.
But chloride can come back and
the nitrogen leave, because it
couldn't become stable by losing
a proton.
So that probably goes on.
But another reaction could
happen instead, which is for
the nitrogen base to attack a
proton here.
So you could do an elimination
reaction, lose HCl, and you
generate, then, ketene, this
funny molecule, which is sort
of an analog of CO2,
except instead of an oxygen, you
have CH2 group here.
Now, that group then could be
attacked by a nucleophile, the
same way CO2 is attacked.
And now you have the nucleophile
attack, and that's
an enolate, so we could draw the
resonance form of it and
we could put a proton on there
from the protonated
nucleophile and get the product,
plus the nucleophile
anion, which is now able to do
it to the next ketene.
OK.
So what we've done is convert a
ketene into an acid
derivative, depending on what
nucleophile we use.
And you can use lots of
different nucleophiles.
Here's, for example, taken from
that Jones textbook, is
sulfur as the nucleophile.
This, they said, was done at dry
ice temperature for three
days, and gave a thioester in
93% yield.
Or instead of base-catalyzed
like this, it
could be aci-catalyzed.
So reaction with t-butyl alcohol
with acid.
So the acid can protonate the
oxygen, then this oxygen can
attack, right, as the
nucleophile, lose the proton,
and you get t-butyl ester, 87%
yield.
Or you can use a nitrogen.
This is done in ethanol water,
and it gives a 75% yield.
Of course, these other things
could've reacted.
The O minus, or the HO minus,
could have reacted
if it were in base.
But it's probably, although it
isn't said so here, it's
probably in acid.
So it's probably an
acid-catalyzed reaction.
Now, then you can have
insertions into acyl-R bonds.
Let me just start this, and
we'll finish it up next time.
So we'll talk about the first
reaction.
You remember this picture?
Who's interesting in this
picture that we
talked about before?
This guy here.
Remember who that is?
What did he do, if you can't
remember his name?
STUDENT: Made triphenylmethyl.
PROFESSOR: He made
triphenylmethyl, right?
That's Gomberg.
So this is the same picture.
And there's Baeyer, who was the
boss of the lab.
But this is Victor Villiger, a
Swiss who was working in the
Munich lab at the time.
And just at 1900, so the same
time that Gomberg was making
triphenylmethyl, the
Baeyer-Villiger reaction was
invented, which inserts oxygen
into an acyl bond.
So let me just do that one
quickly on the board, and then
we'll quit.
So what we're doing is taking R,
O, R, and we're going to insert
an atom in here to make it R, O,
OR.
So change a ketone into an
ester.
And the way it's done is to
react it with a peroxy acid.
So now we have RO minus--
and it is acidic, so we'll take
the OO minus,
O, O.
And now, normally what we think
of is these electrons
come in and lose this group.
But we don't have a leaving
group here, right?
So instead what happens is that
these
electrons come here.
So we have double bond O at the
top, R, and now what's
attached here is O, this O, and
attached to that O is the
other R, and this good
anion has left.
So we ended up by inserting an
oxygen into the C-R bond.
And we're going to talk more
about that next time.